jean marc bonjour alors que les français
et c'est de préparer un défaite qu'ils
soient compatibles avec les contraintes
sanitaires
est ce que cette période va permettre de
sauver les commerçants qui ont
énormément souffert on peut le rappeler
depuis le début de cette crise puisque
la majorité d'entre eux étaient fermées
pendant le confinement
bah écoutez ça va être très compliqué
hein parce que globalement la situation
de crise en général à freiner toutes les
initiatives tous les achats de beaucoup
de français le transfert vers le
e-commerce a d'ailleurs était beaucoup
moins important que ce qu'on pensait on
pensait qu'on aurait un écrasement d
amazonie ou de tousser les commerçants
sur sur internet
en fait ça a pas été tellement le
caillou et un transfert certes mais mais
mais assez modérée alors les deux
semaines qui viennent sont les plus
chargés de l'année
la plupart des commerces font entre 30
et 50% de leur chiffre d'affaires en
décembre alors c'est la raison pour
laquelle il avait d'ailleurs préparé
leurs stocks il se bourre de stock pour
pour justement faire face à cette
demande est bien cette demande elle
n'est pas forcément au rendez vous tout
va jouer cette semaine ça va se jouer
cette semaine
ça va se jouer aussi le week-end
prochain l'activité plus importante que
l'année dernière à la même époque on
fait 20 % de mieux donc ça veut dire
qu'on a un peu de rattrapage mais tous
les commerces sont pas logés à la même
enseigne les commerces alimentaires les
traiteurs marche bien et je vais en
profiter
en plus de la fermeture des restaurants
les commerces non alimentaires eux sont
assez bien reparti depuis la levée du
confinement la levée partielle du
confinement la confection par exemple la
bagagerie la bijouterie l'équipement
produits ménagers il avait d'ailleurs
profité du black friday
je pense aux digital notamment la vente
d'ordinateurs portables tout ça mais
alors vous le disiez le couvre-feu va
les obliger à fermer vers 19h 19h30
puisqu'il faudra être chez soi à à 20h
et ça est bien ici attendais pas il
pensait rester ouverts jusqu'à 22 heures
il y en avait même qu'à préparer qui
avaient préparé un semblant de nocturne
alors à côté vous avez également des
activités qui sont complètement à
l'arrêt alors on va pas revenir sur les
stations de ski qui sont ouvertes mais
les remontées mécaniques qui sont
fermées il n'y aura pas grand monde les
hôtels les restaurants les boîtes de
nuit les théâtres tout ce dont vous avez
parlé les cinémas les côtés distraction
rien
rien en dehors des plateformes de
streaming netflix
alors pour résumer le secteur du
commerce de détail va limiter les dégâts
oui mais ça sera pas euphorique comme ça
l'a été en juillet souvenez-vous en
juillet et en août on avait fait un
tabac
et là notamment juste après le premier
confinement d'explosion là alors tous
ces acteurs là bas ils vont reporter
leurs espoirs sur l'année prochaine
début janvier on attend d'un 192 soldes
qu'ils ont d'ailleurs été reporté au 20
janvier mais mais vraiment c'est pas
c'est pas le moral n'est pas au beau
fixe
alors justement est ce que l'économie
peut rebondir en 2021 et koné
techniquement et financièrement elle
pourrait rebondir tous les ingrédients
sont là la majorité des entreprises
n'ont pas été abîmées beaucoup en ont
profité même pour se réformer s'adapter
alors on parle beaucoup des entreprises
en difficulté et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
zones d'entreprises en difficulté mais
elle était en difficulté avant donc la
crise à un peu aggravé et accélérer la
dégradation mais pour le reste et bien
l'appareil de production est en assez
bon état il suffit de remettre la clé
dans les moteurs et puis ça ça peut
redémarrer il ya de l'argent d'ailleurs
pour redémarrer
il a énormément des pagnes puisque on
vient de le voir les français n'ont pas
n'ont pas consommé l'aîné contrat de
travail ont été préservés grâce à
l'allocation chômage et puis a quand
même eu beaucoup dead de distribuer donc
une partie de cette épargne pourrait
permet d'ailleurs à l'état aujourd'hui
de s'endetter à un taux négatif donc ça
ne coûte rien ce qui permet de remettre
des liquidités dans dans le circuit cela
dit on aura beaucoup de mal à retrouver
en 2021
les niveaux d'activité d'avant la crise
du coc vide pour trois raisons très
simples à d'abord parce que la majorité
des entreprises peut redémarrer vous à
vous en avez cure ont du mal je vous le
disais à redresser il ya même des
défaillances d'entreprises sont des
défaillances d'opportunités il ya
beaucoup de plans sociaux
et puis vous avez des secteurs qui sont
bloqués le transport aérien par exemple
est bloquée l'hôtellerie est bloqué ils
auront du mal à redémarrer très vite et
puis la deuxième raison c'est que on va
avoir besoin d'investissements
l'investissement de mutation un de
l'état a promis un plan de relance de
100 milliards à partir du 1er janvier
mais ça c'était avant 2
la deuxième vague l'état va devoir
remettre un peu au pot pour compenser
les dégâts delà de cette deuxième vague
et puis aider les malades de l'industrie
j'ajoute qu'il va falloir faire des
arbitrages
ils vont être assez politiquement
délicat entre les aides aux progrès les
aides à la mutation industrielle et puis
aussi les aide à la transition
écologique qui sont pas forcément
générateurs de croissance rapide et 2 et
de création d'emplois dans l'immédiat
enfin il ya une troisième raison c'est
qu'il faut que ça redémarre partout dans
le monde parce que on peut pas
redémarrer tout seul on est dépendant de
l'espace européen on mêmes dépendants du
commerce international sinon on risque
la campagne de fourniture de deux
clients non le facteur clé ça va être
évidemment des traitements le facteur
clé
ça va être évidemment le vaccin
si en août par exemple de l'année
prochaine les populations sont vaccinés
ben ça redémarrera assez vite parce que
le facteur confiance sera restaurée on
se retrouvera un peu comme en juillet de
cette année après le premier confinement
sont historiques
mais on a quand même perdu 12% de
richesse cette année on en est à 10% de
chômage 101% de dette donc le bilan est
très très mauvais 12% de richesse cette
année faudrait refaire trois ou quatre
pour cent de plus pour pouvoir
redémarrer la machine s'est donc fait
pour gagner presque 15 20%
ça me paraît complètement impossible à
faire en 2021 si le vaccin ne marche pas
eh bien il faudra encore attendre
et puis on va attendre plus ça va coûter
cher merci beaucoup jean-marc pour ce
décryptage jean marc sylvestre et
idéaliste économique pour rt france en
tout cas